this morning we do remember the longest
serving republican u.s senator in
history that would be orrin hatch he
died on saturday he was 88 years old
hatch represented utah and the state for
42 years spanning seven presidents from
jimmy carter to donald trump he
sponsored or co-sponsored more than 750
bills that later became law at the end
of his senate tenure hatch became a
staunch
ally rather president trump he also
played a vital role in crafting the
republicans
2017 tax cuts hatch was a reliable
conservative vote throughout his career
but he was also known for working with
democrats on issues like stem cell
research and expanding children's health
insurance before he retired in 2019
hatch issued a sharp warning about the
dangers of party politics listen to this
on both the left and the right
the bar of decency
has been set so low that jumping over it
is no longer the objective
limbo is the new name of the game
how low can you go
all the evidence points to an unsettling
truth
the senate as an institution
is in crisis or at least maybe in crisis
president biden who served in the senate
with hatch for 32 years said in the
statement that he was quote the fighter
who never humored a bully or shied away
from a challenge he was quite simply an
american original